[Música]
ella tiene 27 años está en sudáfrica en
un hotel es de noche llegó ese día
porque le habían pedido de un diario de
buenos aires que retratará las últimas
horas de un prófugo traficante de armas
a quien había apresado ese día
suena el teléfono
ella tiende sólo hay una respiración del
otro lado ella está aterrada pero
también fascinada por esa aventura
ella tiene 37 años son las 5 de la tarde
y se dio cuenta que no había comido en
todo el día
totalmente
involucrada en tratar de hacer encajar
unos indicadores cuantitativos que
pudieran dar cuenta de una evaluación de
un proyecto de desarrollo sostenible que
se estaba realizando para américa
latina'
la comunicación con los humanos en esa
época de su vida que sobre todo vía web
cuando contacta con otros profesionales
es en algún congreso en el exterior
ella tiene 47 años
está en su estudio en la mesa unos tipos
calentitos mate té
por las ventanas grandes entre el sol y
entre el verde de los árboles y las
plantas del jardín en el que está ese
estudio que está conversando
con una persona a la que está tratando
de ayudar en tomar una decisión muy
importante en su vida que tiene que ver
con decidir si sigue o no con el socio
con el cual hace años habían fundado una
empresa juntos se están viendo cuáles
son los pasos posibles a seguir los pros
y contras y cómo planificar un futuro
posible
todas esas ellas soy yo
esos son mis ciclos laborales
durante 12 años fui periodista otros 10
años hice consultoría en temas de
desarrollo sostenible para américa
latina y españa y en los últimos años me
dedico justamente a asesorar a las
personas en sus procesos de cambio
laboral
pensar en términos de ciclos nos ayuda a
ponernos en perspectiva básicamente en
dos sentidos por una parte podemos
pensar nuestro presente teniendo en
cuenta tanto nuestro pasado como como
queremos proyectarnos hacia adelante y
por otra parte pensar nuestro presente
entendiendo que ciclos atravesamos y nos
atraviesan ciclos personales ciclos con
nuestras familias con nuestras amistades
que van mutando a lo largo del tiempo
ciclos también que se cruzan nuestros
con los ciclos del país o de la sociedad
en la que estamos
somos un punto en una trama de ciclos en
un entramado de ciclos que atravesamos y
nos atraviesan
la naturaleza nos cuenta clarito el tema
de los ciclos la luna lleva un ciclo
cada mes
las estaciones se suceden cada año el
día le sigue a la noche la noche le
sigue al día y nosotros mismos somos
naturaleza nosotros nacemos crecemos
morimos y dejamos lugar a otros que
crecen
perdón nacen crecen y mueren
entonces
dentro de estos distintos ciclos que
nosotros vamos atravesando
están los ciclos laborales que son en
los que yo más trabajo
todos tenemos seguramente en esta sala
algún tipo de ciclo laboral en el que
estamos transitando
algunos pueden estar en un ciclo muy
vinculado con su vocación otros pueden
estar transitando un ciclo muy vinculado
con algún mandato familiar otros pueden
estar transitando un ciclo con un socio
y otros un ciclo solos algunos un ciclo
como empleados otros un ciclo como
trabajadores por cuenta propia
algunos pueden estar transitando su
primer ciclo laboral tal vez y otros
quizás el último algunos tal vez cruzan
actualmente un ciclo donde los intereses
propios están muy dispersos y otros por
el contrario tal vez están cursando
algún ciclo donde los intereses propios
lograron fusionar los
mi actual ciclo laboral transcurre en
modo delta delta es la letra griega que
simboliza el cambio
y como les decía lo que yo hago es
acompañar a la gente en esos tránsitos
de cambiar de un ciclo laboral al otro
hay un momento clave en la vida laboral
que tiene que ver justamente con pasar
de un ciclo a otro es una transición
y si hay alguien que sabe mucho de
transiciones son los cangrejos
los cangrejos
tienen su propio caparazón
que los estructuras que les da un borde
para defenderse del exterior es una
especie de escudo
que los defienden pero a la vez para
crecer esa misma característica de
dureza de solidez es la que les impide
seguir ganando volumen entonces llega un
momento en la vida de un cangrejo en que
tiene que retirarse
para poder incubar un cambio importante
que tiene que ver con queso que en algún
momento le daba tanta fortaleza hoy lo
está limitando
tal vez le pasa a alguno de ustedes que
pensaron soñaban pensaban entrar en
algún trabajo lo lograron
primero les resultó desafiante había
mucho para aprender y tal vez
actualmente lo perciben más como algo
tedioso como algo que ya no les resuena
algo así le pasa al cangrejo con su
caparazón
lo que hace el cangrejo es retirarse
para poder generar ese cambio lo está
incubando nosotros también en general
los cambios estos nos vamos sintiendo
internamente a veces ni siquiera los
podemos poner en palabras al principio
sólo sentimos tal vez mucha
insatisfacción mucha cerrazón y como
mucho lo podemos traducir en una queja
pero no en un deseo sobre algo que va a
venir más adelante que todavía tal vez
ni siquiera podemos identificar qué es
este momento del cangrejo también se
parece a nuestros momentos de cambio
laboral porque al quedarse sin caparazón
para poder seguir creciendo el cangrejo
queda con una especie de piel gruesa que
reemplaza esa caparazón y que le permite
ir ganando volumen nutrirse tomar mucha
agua y a la vez es un momento de mucha
fertilidad justamente porque hay una
caparazón perdón ya no hay una caparazón
que impida su contacto con el otro
entonces estos momentos de transición si
bien son muy complejos son muy ricos son
muy nutritivos
y para eso quisiera traerles algunas
otras partes del cangrejo para que
puedan eventualmente si están en una
situación así poder pensar en
herramientas cangrejas y poder
aplicarlas a ustedes mismos y el momento
que estén viviendo unas son los ojos del
cangrejo
el cangrejo tiene ojos que están por
encima de su cuerpo eso nos invita a
poder poner nosotros por encima de
nuestro cuerpo a nuestros ojos y poder
entonces mirar más allá de nosotros
mismos del momento actual que estamos
viviendo y en esa proyección que podemos
hacer más allá de nosotros mismos y este
presente que tal vez nos incomoda
podemos pensar
cuál es la esencia del futuro ciclo que
quiero encarar qué cosa no me quiero
perder de ninguna manera
tal vez estaban trabajando por cuenta
propia y están hartos de la
incertidumbre que eso genera y lo que
quieren que el próximo ciclo sí o sí
tenga estabilidad laboral y todos los
meses poder cobrar un sueldo tal vez por
el contrario están hartos de los jefes y
dice en mi próximo ciclo laboral sí o sí
va a ser por mi cuenta
también el cangrejo tiene las patas
muchas patas
tiene ocho patas esas patas le permiten
al cangrejo escaparse rápido de donde no
tiene que estar y además saben que el
cangrejo camina de costado
entonces la propuesta en términos de
cambio laboral
es que puedan probar chiquitos para
saber qué es lo que quieren ir a buscar
en el próximo ciclo por ejemplo a veces
alcanza con si hay algún tema que les
interesa que los convoca pero nunca se
animaron a acercarse a ese tema poder
hacer algún curso corto sobre eso es una
ventana en la que se asoman pispeando un
poco qué contenidos hay si los enfoques
le interesan qué tipo de personas
circulan por ese tema y por el campo que
rodea a ese tema y después se van y
siguen así a un otro espacio un otro
ámbito que les permita ir pisando
distintos distintas realidades distintos
escenarios posibles
por otra parte están las antenas que
están al lado de los ojos tiene mucho al
cangrejo mucho por afuera de si estas
antenas son sensores los sensores le
permiten a los congresos a los cangrejos
percibir la humedad la temperatura pero
también el alimento y los peligros
externos con los que se puedan encontrar
nosotros también podemos pelear nuestros
sensores en un momento de transición
laboral y pensar por ejemplo con qué
personas tenemos que contar para este
cambio a quien necesitamos tener cerca
ellos saben de nosotros
tal vez una docente tal vez un familiar
una colega un amigo pero también así
como los sensores detectan lo favorable
detectan el peligro y está bueno que
pensemos de quienes tenemos que correr
nos un poco quienes nos están
obstruyendo el camino para eso nuestros
sensores
así que de esto se trata un poco la
transición laboral como decía antes es
un momento complejo y rico nutritivo es
de vulnerabilidad pero también es de
crecimiento entonces los invito a que si
ustedes en este momento están en un
momento de cambio de ciclo donde puede
ser que primero sepan lo que no quieren
y no necesariamente todavía sepan lo que
sí quieren que entonces hagan esto
cangrejos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]